this is the 2017 audi r8 spyder the
latest version looks great with Audi's
famous honeycomb grille wedge-shaped
head lights and LED diode lights inside
them the r8 spyder retains the forward
position of the passenger compartment
the highly accentuated wheel arches and
the long back of its predecessor but at
14 and a half feet long it's a little
bit shorter and a little bit wider than
previous years the great thing about
this car if you love audi is that you
can have all of the aggression of the r8
coupe but you get it in a more stylish I
would say more fun model in the
convertible edition this thing is crazy
it has a v10 540 horsepower engine
that's way more horsepower than last
year's edition and if you get this new
version it will hit 62 miles per hour in
3.6 seconds well under last year's for
second sprint time top speed is just
over 197 miles per hour the car also has
new driving dynamic systems and
performance modes upgraded components
and increase rigidity throughout the
body howdy says it will go on sale later
this year pricing has yet to be
announced